Hi Siri President of the European Parliament
Madam President of the European Commission
Ladies and gentlemen when
across Europe we face a pandemic
that generated the greatest economic and
social crisis of the Second World War brings
health benefits we are at the heart of
bankruptcy the convening of the conference
on the  it is a message of trust and
hope
Hello all Europeans that we will
overcome the pandemic and overcome the
crisis there is hope that together we will
build a Europe of the future that is
fair digital  that here in
the European Parliament in the commission in the
Council work so that we can
reach this agreement we know the same
vision about the future the future of Europe
but that is precisely why the
diversity of forecasts we can
overcome divisions and recover the
presumed and reinforce consumption as always
happened  throughout the year
AND since the signing of the Treaty of Rome
The  i and the time for this discussion is now Get
ready now second of the Future
the union needs to be strengthened with the
strength of Citizenship so this
cannot be a conference of
institutions on institutions a
conference on what the future of
our union
in a conference  in
at a conference on policies
excuse your Will
the conjuncture inscriptions today
naturally public health the
eurobarometer allowed concern
our fellow citizens and that our
response to economic and
political issues medications tourism
is a strategic agenda For the
European future and capable  to promote
European interests and values ​​on the
world stage But we need Europeans to
embrace this purpose and its
ultimate recipient
and that is why this conference is so
important because it will allow and
bring Europeans the public space it matters that
European citizens expect them
their representatives so that
public policies respond to the
needs  day-to-day ssities so that
nobody feels we shouldn't waste any more
time in
[Applause]
in Aparecida Ursula Von der leyen nail the
president
the future of Europe
the hunger of its gerop Stars leading the
World at the full creativity and Hide in
And then it will be the dance
And then I need to warn your family
And then rotate as astron Boy if it is Freedom
and wisdom and World of Life this and
much more is my dream of Europe One out
of reach Fifty Million Dreams
i took want to have about you opi when
it was launched in
november William peut faire lire e arme
na Live
i took the essay Fashion on the country
Friends on the future of Europe  is made
of White Now on
and they Despite of free is one of people
and well Get It On
and you
know menstruated  listening
to the cross-border is pou  co of Us
the iPhone study is not an option to let
me be very quickly Ó
the Viscount Friends On The Field of
Europe is not just has to go Beyond The
House has to go before we want is what
we want to hear from you up inside  and a
full drivers It took to the Streets and
Powers of the World of fashion
o sul Edson Deus Escolha has points
Sofia merges fairies
Hello all absurd filter not in Dream
Setúbal thank you
there
andthere
and there
and
there  there